E aí
[Música]
o Olá gente tudo bem Boa tarde um prazer
estar aqui e hoje eu vim trazer um tema
para vocês eu vim falar de storytelling
né O Poder do storytelling com uma
tecnologia que transforma vidas eu já
quero começar com era uma vez não é
assim que a gente começa a contar nossas
histórias então era uma vez um rei lá na
época das Mil e Uma Noites o rei shariar
que ele se casou com uma mulher e depois
de algum tempo casado ele descobriu que
foi traído bom Que que aconteceu ele
decidiu se vingar né então ele decidiu
se casar com uma mulher a cada dia e
depois da lua-de-mel ele matava essa
esposa por quê Porque ele tinha medo de
ser traído bom E aí chegou a veja
Sheherazade então o rei shariar casou
com Sheherazade e Sheherazade muito
inteligente tem medo ser morta na noite
da lua de mel a Sheherazade começou a
contar uma história para o rei na
primeira noite e toda vez próximo do
Amanhecer a xerazade
a história e dizia o rei que só
terminaria no dia seguinte e assim foi
de após dia dia após dia o que que
aconteceu no final o rei shariar
desistiu de matar Sheherazade E aí eles
viveram felizes para sempre porque que
eu tô contando essa história para falar
do Poder do storytelling Ou seja a
Sheherazade usou storytelling Ela contou
uma história conseguiu emocionar o rei
conectar-se com ele e de alguma forma
ele foi impactado ele teve de alguma
forma resgatou alguma memória e assim a
vida dele seguiu em frente porque que eu
tô contando isso para falar desse poder
mesmo do storytelling então para gente
começar a falar de storytelling eu quero
falar um pouquinho de contexto de mundo
eu quero trazer para vocês uma coisa
super interessante que eu gosto muito de
falar sobre tudo que a gente tá vivendo
hoje e como isso se conecta com
storytelling vamos ver Olha só eu vou
falar de uma Filosofia de uma palavra
o gás da filosofia alemã do século 18 e
19 que diz que o seguinte ele é o
retrato de uma época como a sociedade se
comporta como as histórias são contadas
Então se a gente vai trazer aí o
primeiro momento que a gente vivia lá
atrás no passado um pouquinho antes né
de toda essa globalização de toda essa
era da tecnologia que a gente vive hoje
no momento que eu chamo de sólido né da
modernidade sólida ou seja Vivemos um
contexto de mundo muito mais estrutural
estruturado né as pessoas conseguiam
fazer planejamentos mais a longo prazo
as coisas eram mais calmas a gente não
tinha a tecnologia no nosso dia a dia e
como que as histórias eram contadas
através de livros e enciclopédias de
contadores de história e aí a gente cai
no novo contexto de mundo no novo site
gás que eu chamo de Mundo líquido the
modern
o segundo Zygmunt Bauman né Ou seja a
gente cai nesse mundo de transformações
exponenciais de tecnologia evoluindo
cada vez mais no mundo volátil é incerto
complexo e amigo o mundo boca né como
todo mundo já sabe que eu gosto de falar
sobre isso bom e nesse mundo né a gente
vê aí que uma quantidade infinita de
informações sendo geradas de conteúdo
sendo produzidos né para vocês terem uma
ideia nós produzimos muito mais
informação de 2003 até hoje do que do
início da civilização até 2003 e como as
histórias são contadas né nesse momento
nessa realidade líquida elas são
contadas através de livros através de
memórias e também através da tecnologia
a tecnologia ela facilitou o acesso a
histórias antigas né que a gente trazia
aí de tempos atrás e também
e deu a possibilidade de contar novas
histórias usando todas essas a Essas
tecnologias digitais que estão à nossa
disposição bom e aí a gente cai a gente
sai dessa realidade líquido e a gente
cai na academia nessa realidade nova que
de repente desestruturou tudo a gente se
viu no momento onde a gente teve que se
recolher para dentro de casa a gente
viveu um causa uma turbulência absoluta
e a gente teve que rever uma série de
coisas nas nossas vidas tivemos de rever
conceitos propósitos valores e até mesmo
entender a nossa história ou seja tudo
isso afetou de alguma forma as nossas
vidas então quando eu falo que a
pandemia ela trouxe essa nova realidade
para gente ela fez com que a gente
entendesse refletisse o que que eu quero
ouvir daqui para frente o que eu vou
contar sobre a minha vida daqui para
frente porque a gente sabe que tudo
mudou
e nada melhor que a gente usar o
storytelling como uma tecnologia uma
tecnologia da comunicação para poder
inspirar as pessoas para poder emocionar
para poder conectar as pessoas e também
transformar a vida das pessoas através
de uma de uma narrativa envolvente e
Atrativa a verdade gente aqui quando a
gente fala de storytelling a gente
precisa também saber que todos nós somos
storytellers todos nós somos contadores
de histórias o storytelling não é sobre
o que a gente faz é sobre o que nós
somos porque nós temos essa capacidade
de contar uma história Quem de vocês não
tá lá na sua rede social contando uma
história quem de você que vai que liga o
seu computador se conecta a internet Vai
no YouTube e conta uma história da sua
vida uma história de superação que que
você faz você usa a tecnologia seu favor
e você usa
a pele para contar a sua história bom se
eu tô falando aqui você um contador de
história e que a tecnologia ela tá aí
para facilitar Eu gosto muito de uma
frase de um de um de um Historiador de
um escritor chamado Terence mckenna que
ele disse que a tecnologia é uma
extensão das nossas mentes E aí se ela é
uma extensão das nossas mentes o
storytelling é uma extensão dos nossos
pensamentos é aquilo que você pensa que
você quer compartilhar aquilo que você
deseja contar aquilo que você quer
contar que possa transformar a vida de
alguém que possa mudar a vida de alguém
o aquilo que você viveu e você superou
que você conseguiu resolver e que você
quer contar para essas pessoas como elas
podem fazer o mesmo e aí quando eu falo
sobre isso o que a gente precisa
entender se o storytelling e a
tecnologia caminham tão juntos muito
mais agora nesse mundo que a gente tá
vivendo o quê
a encontrar a ferramenta ideal para
poder levar a sua história para sua
audiência para as pessoas porque nesse
momento exato depois de tudo isso que a
gente tá vivendo com a pandemia o que a
gente precisa mais do que tudo é
entender que a jornada da nossa
audiência a jornada do seu cliente ela
importa e muito agora importa porque o
seu cliente porque a sua audiência ela
mudou depois disso tudo dessa pandemia
as pessoas não são mais as mesmas e a
gente sabe disso e a gente sabe que as
histórias não serão mais as mesmas e
mais do que isso a gente sabe que as
pessoas elas estão com novas
necessidades com novas motivações com
novos desejos e com muitas dores também
e cabe a você Cabe a mim saber como você
vai contar uma história para essa pessoa
como que a sua marca vai impactar essas
pessoas e vai chegar até essas pessoas
tá aí O Grande Desafio das marcas
a cantar as pessoas nesse novo momento
que a gente está vivendo agora tenho
psicólogo chamado Jerome brunner que ele
diz que as pessoas têm até 20 vezes mais
chances de se lembrar né de uma marca de
uma pessoa de um produto de um projeto
de uma ideia se estiver associado a uma
história a uma história real a uma
história envolvente e para que você
possa contar a sua história de verdade
trabalhar o seu storytelling né Para que
você possa impactar sua audiência você
precisa ter uma boa narrativa e uma boa
narrativa é saber quando você vai
emocionar essa pessoa o que você tá
mostrando para essa pessoa O que você tá
fazendo de conteúdo real relevante de
impacto né e mostrar para as pessoas que
você conseguiu vencer um obstáculo que
você conseguiu passar pela pandemia de
alguma forma e que você teve algo que
você aprendeu daí é
a usar o storytelling de entender que
para chegar até a sua audiência você
precisa emocionar lá você precisa se
interagir com ela e precisa que o seu
conteúdo ele seja atrativo então e antes
de mais nada se é super importante falar
disso agora é que não dá mais para gente
contar histórias falsas mentirosas as
pessoas não querem mais ouvir mentiras
as pessoas estão cansadas de fake News
Então quando você levar sua história
para seu gerência seja você o personagem
principal e seja real que a sua história
ela seja verdadeira porque a gente não
quer mais ouvir histórias de pessoas que
são que estão ali construindo
personagens que não são reais por trás
da tela é aproveitar a tecnologia para
contar sua história verdadeira o mais
bacana nisso a gente vê um Case recente
a uma história a um Case do Boticário
que ele contratou 200 influenciador
Olá mulheres 40 mais acima de 40 anos a
para poder para que elas fossem
influenciadores da marca só que Essas
mulheres são reais tem histórias reais
são como você como eu não são
personagens não sou influenciadoras Com
milhões de seguidores são
influenciadores com poucos seguidores
mas com histórias verdadeiras e é isso
que as marcas agora estão buscando
encontrar pessoas com histórias reais
diante disso O storytelling a tecnologia
vão caminhar juntos um com o outro
sempre lado a lado porque esse é o
momento que a gente tá vivendo desse
boom da tecnologia e segundo digital
esse momento né de tantas transformações
exponenciais nessa área da tecnologia
que chegou para gente que acelerou o
futuro e mais do que isso o storytelling
e a tecnologia vão continuar conectando
pessoas vão continuar impactando as
pessoas gerando emoções resgatando
memórias significativas
que horas que até então você nem
imaginava que existiam E aí diante disso
é importante você usar a tecnologia de
uma forma que seja benéfica para você e
para as pessoas aquilo que você for
levar de conteúdo real a sua história
pense sempre para quem você tá contando
isso e cuidado para não usar a
tecnologia como algo que vá prejudicar
outras pessoas você tem que contar sua
história de uma forma verdadeira usando
a tecnologia a seu favor EA favor das
pessoas mais do que isso tem uma frase
de Joseph Campbell que ele diz que a
gente precisa se dispor né a gente
precisa abrir mão daquela vida que a
gente planejou e a fim de encontrar a
vida que espera por nós é enxergar é
olhar para frente o que espera por você
daqui para frente depois disso tudo que
você tá vivendo é uma nova história é
uma nova vida que você tá construído a
partir de agora depois de tudo o que
e eu que você vivenciou nessa pandemia
Então pense bem sobre isso sabe por quê
que eu tô te dizendo isso porque daqui
para frente o que espera você é o futuro
a pandemia celebrou o seu futuro e nesse
futuro você precisa construir uma
história que fale de diversidade que
fale de inclusão que fale de empatia que
Connect verdadeiramente as pessoas e
você precisa enxergar a sua audiência
essas pessoas não como recursos mas
enxergar essas pessoas verdadeiramente
como elas são como uma fonte inesgotável
de saber de conhecimento de histórias e
a partir daí você usar o storytelling
como fonte de inspiração por seu
conteúdo então o recado que eu deixo é
que você abrace as suas histórias abrace
aquilo que você vem construindo na sua
vida e enxergue daqui para frente Como
que você vai fazer para usar a
tecnologia e
e a sua nova história uma nova história
que você tá vivendo agora com tudo o que
você aprendeu com tudo que você superou
e com tudo aquilo que realmente está
fazendo diferença na sua vida nunca se
esqueça que uma história que você
constrói Ela traz legado os profundos e
verdadeiros para sua vida então eu vou
te falar uma frase que eu gosto muito de
dizer sempre quando eu faço uma palestra
e Principalmente nesse momento agora
nesses nove meses que a gente está
vivendo de pandemia Se você me conhece
baseado no que eu era a nove meses atrás
você já não me conhece mais a minha
evolução é constante permita-me contar a
minha história novamente e eu termino
fazendo a seguinte pergunta
E qual vai ser história que você vai
contar a partir de agora pense nisso